hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast circulating tumor cells
clinical utility challenges and future
prospects presented by dr. Queen May
director and professor Department of
Laboratory Medicine the University of
Texas MD Anderson Cancer Center we are
excited to bring you this educational
web cap presented by Lavery's the
leading scientific social networking
website and provider of virtual events
and webinars advancing scientific
collaboration and learning on Julie Sam
Roth of libraries and I'll be your
moderator for today's event before we
begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button located in the lower left of the
presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation also please notice
that you will be viewing the
presentation and a slide window to
enlarge the window just click on a
screen icon located in the lower right
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem this is an educational webinar
and this offers free continuing
education credit after the webinar is
over please click on the C e button
located on the bottom left-hand corner
of your webpage and follow the process
of obtaining your credit please join me
in welcoming dr. King men I will now
turn the presentation over to him thank
you for the introduction hello everybody
it's a pleasure to share with you the
current advance of circulating tumor
cells so in this talk I'm going to give
you a brief review of the previous
principal
technology and the clinical utility of
the detection of circulating tumor cells
then we have discussed the current
challenge and a future perspective of
the CTC
and then hopefully at the end we'll be
able to identify those potential
clinical use and a research interest of
CDC detection especially for molecular
profiling in the area of personalized
cancer medicine so circulating tumor
cells was the first described in 1869 by
an Australia pathologist dr. Tom's ash
was so under mark crew he a fundus
actually by accident he found those
sales were untenable to those primary
tumor cells in a patient blood a patient
with metastasis so because that was a
found in the blood in peripheral blood
therefore he named those cells were
circulating tumor cells so circulating
tumor cells by the meaning those cells
then have entered into the vasculature
and the certain circulate in the blood
and release across from a primary
soldier the tumor cells circulating
tumor cells have found in a very small
low number in the peripheral blood it's
about 1 to 10 sayers in peripheral per
milliliter with peripheral blood in
patients with metastatic cancer
typically about one tumor cells to 1
million leukocytes in the blood it's
almost like a funnier for a needle in
the haystack right only a small portion
of a CTC when they released in
circulation can survive the half-life is
about one to two hours so within a 24
hours it's only less than 0.1% of these
cells can it survive but only 0.01% of
tumor cells in the circulation can
survive and also to produce and
metastases the tumor cells are
circulating the blood will be delivered
and transferred into the removed organs
and to continue to grow
and produce the metastases those organs
are often involved are those land boom
and the livers so after the first
described discovery almost 150 years ago
and nothing has been not much has been
made since then and butter till the last
decade following the advance of
Technology and the increment of the
detection sensitivity and a number of
technologies have been established and
validated so this paper just summarized
a variety of technologies being used for
the detection for circulating tumor
cells as you can see basically that can
be classified or categorized as antibody
based temperature of answer and also
using the physical characteristics of
the tumor cells to isolate to count
tumor cells and based on the size of the
shared and others like function and say
that's more biological function cell
culture and say and also some other
fruit cytometry so for the imminent
actions but still the eminences antibody
based capture as a as a major method now
there has been used as you can see in
this box green box those two highlighted
when it's a cell search the other one is
add an attached or talked a little bit
detail about their method so CTC is a
conspirator searchers indicate you know
during especially in the last two
decades and a variety of technologies
has been established validate those
mostly include even attempt to even a
certain chemistry flu title chemistry
nanoparticles microscope physical
temperature biological function and say
and also most recently moving to PCR and
even into molecular sequencing those
technologies are being used to detect
the tumor cells however there are no
Universal markers been
standardized or user nowadays but on the
other hand most for the 232 tumor cells
almost 85% of solid tumor cells of a
ceiling or in orange so patterns and the
expression of epithelial cell adhesion
molecular is widely used
therefore CTC can be identified by the
expression of severe markers such as
epic am and sub keratin the current to
establish the method for citizen
detection the all best see each time
temperature technology so the Tilted our
method is damaged our cell search which
is fda-approved using immuno magnetic
and a Florence measured the second as a
has no test which is approved in Europe
the first part is still use F cam
antibody for the temperature of CTC for
the second apart the detection the use
rt-pcr is measured so just share with
you briefly with the cell search
technology again these the FDA approved
so these cells such as they consists of
two main components so one is the Auto
prep part which is just to isolate and
capture the CTC from the whole blood
using the immuno magnetic nanoparticle
coated antibody specifically against the
egg-cam
so the second part is to use the
Florence
specific Florence antibody conjugated to
standard tumor cells and then analyzed
under microscope so in those cells tumor
cells can be undignified by the security
anybody which is specifically against
our decorating age 18 and 19 for the
starter plasma and showing the futures
stain the greens and started Ranma pant
is staying for the nucleus his purple
was purple and also cd45 and negative
has to be which to exclude the
leukocytes in the blood but there for
the CCC is
and a defined by f can positive gk+ cd45
negative and that is positive in general
the detection of a CTC can be used for
the prognosis and also emani's in the
therapeutic response in cancer of
patients so a number of studies have
demonstrated an increase the CTC the
number of CTC in peripheral blood is
associated with the decreased
progression-free swallow and decrease
overall survival in patients with
metastatic breast cancer colorectal
cancer or prostate cancer detection CDC
can also be used to monitor therapeutic
response patient with the persistently
elevated CTC count suggests an effective
therapy and also the development of
resistance so let me show you briefly
with those milestone studies which
eventually led to the FDA approval for
the CTC currently FDA has approved two
as a to hazard the other four to three
types of cancer when the metastatic
breast cancer was approved by FDA in
2004 metastatic colorectal cancer
approved 2007 and the metastatic
prostate cancer was approved by FDA in
2008 with a different cutoff for example
the color of CPT graves unequal than
five CTC in the detecting in 7.5
military blood for breast cancer and the
prostate cancer but for the colorectal
cancer the cutoff in the 3 CPC again the
early studies have shown that the
detection of space/time CTC can predict
the prognosis and also the survival the
left panel picture shows the progression
free survival and the right panel shows
the overall survival as you can see on
the Left panel
the Green Line shows the patient with
CTC less than five so in this group
patient with the fewer than five CT CT
tag has longer over as a progression
free survival and you can see the two
line the blue line and the red line that
said clearly separated so that on the
other hand the group a patient with CTC
Grey's and file has shorter survivor
time and the poor prognosis the media a
survivor time is for the CCDC less than
five to seven months but for the CTC
gregandfi patient group it's only two
point seven miles which is about half of
the survival time if we look at the
right panel the green curve again that's
the group patient with the CTC less than
five has overall longer with us while
the median survival time almost twenty
two months while in the patient a group
of patients with the higher number of
CTC greater than five and only eleven
months against about half of that the
survival shorter of the saliva time this
clearly indicate the CDC the detection
of CTG can be used to predict the
prognosis and also the outcomes of
survival survival time so how about the
myth therapy's detection with CTC which
means that during the course or
monitoring the disease the cause of CTE
so again on the Left panel you can see
the blue line again this means this
group version shows you know it's a
bikini and the best one ticket is two
less than five but during the course of
a therapy
I wish it's about three to four months
the cause for therapy and again the CTC
is less than five as this group patients
have very longer and better survival
compared to the other group but if you
look again the grey curve also even
though in the beginning the baseline
ctc's number is high greater than five
but in the course for therapy the CCC
number reduced to late
five which means this group of patient
responds to therapy right and again
issues to similar prognosis and survival
again but on the other hand the left
curve red or yellow even though you have
a bikini of course if you have it
beginning your vessel high ctc and
during the course ECC you have a poor
survival or shoulder survival time poor
prognosis but even though in the
beginning you have a CT see less than
five but during the course of therapy
the CT T increase of become greater than
five again that indicates the sterile
tubes it might be a resistant
oh poor prognosis and you can see
clearly with the shorter survival time
and the left panel just shows the number
of the detection of a CT number actually
magic work very well to the clinical
status so again the blue line indicates
the CTC laser and file in the beginning
of the baseline and also during the
course of therapy less than five and has
complete response which means a very
good prognosis is also clinically
interval the response very complete
but on the other hand if we look the red
line so at the beginning the CTC is
great and file are consistently
persistently elevated CTC during the
course which has a very poor prognosis
again it's a very progressive disease so
again this recent study approved from a
seventeen European centers
twenty to include 20 studies almost two
thousand patients for the metastatic
breast cancer that clearly shows that
detection of CTC can predict progression
free survival and also overall swab on
the Left panel just shows the
progression free swallow the blue line
is means the group patients with the CTC
number less than five again it has a
longer better survival than the red line
which represents the patient of group
patient with the CTC number grades and
five similarly the left right line and
right
right panel shows again with the COC TCD
taken in patient has played a longer
survival compared to the CTC number of
grades and five groups so how about the
metastatic colorectal cancer again the
baseline CPC can predict the progression
free survival and the shows on the Left
panel to blue the the blue line again
that means the group of patients with CT
sees less than five so which it has a
longer better survival curve compared to
the yellow line we should represent a
group of patient with high CTC number
again but this cutoff for colorectal
cancer is the 3 CT T 3 T pcs so the
right panel shows the overall survival
and the blue line again it will
represent the group of patients with the
CTC number less than 3 and it has longer
better slab and compared to the group of
patients with the high number of CTC so
similarly during the therapy during the
course of therapies the detection will
CTC can still pretty predict the
prognosis again the left panel shows the
you know different group various group
at the beginning less than 3 that like
shows a solid green blue line and the
during the course of therapy is 3 to 5
weeks and the city list illness and 5
and has the longest survival and the
best of prognosis compresses other group
even though the stick the source blue
line which means a group initially is
the baseline CDC is greater than 3 but
as during the course Sarah P reduced to
lay sensory again relative a better
survival compared to the other group
especially the wound you know in the
beginning of the best buys the CPC high
but it during the course the CDC numbers
still high as as the words the group
with the prognosis on the right panel
panel again that shows Oh
again the clinical status and similarly
that the CDC number of the century it
has indicates clinical it's non
progressive disease but on the other
hand in the CDC always elevated in the
beginning during the course which means
always a program progressive disease so
clearly indicating the detection of a
CTC can predict the prognosis also the
survival overall survival and
progression-free survival so let's move
on to the metastatic prostate cancer
again you can see with the detection of
a CTC from the baseline level and again
the group of patients with CTC less than
five and showing the green green line
that has a longer much longer
slava time compared again this overall
survival curve compared to the red line
group which represent a group of
patients prostate cancer patients with
the CTC number greater than five so the
medium survival time is almost twice for
CCDC less than five group compared to
the sequencing high number of CTC group
so the layer panel again shows the
immediate sarahfey during the therapy
the number of CTC again it can predict
the survival I clearly shows it it shows
the separation with two lines the green
line the red line again the green line
always represent a group a patient with
a fewer CTC number less than five
compared the group of a cetacean with 60
number higher than five again the median
time survival time almost two to
threefold longer in the CTC
less than five group and has better
prognosis so the right panel just shows
them again it's sort of an ROC curve it
was the prediction of the base and
mortality with the detection with CTC
Simpson you know the peers compared to
TSA TSA is a biomarker us mainly tumor
marker by tremor marker used
to monitor therapy and managing for the
many management of prostate cancer again
it shows them detection of CTC has
better performance and prediction
compare the PSA under the ROC curve so
and it just indicated the measurement
and detection with CTC can be used for
monitor patient 30 degrees pass and also
to predict the prognosis and those are
demonstrated in those studies however in
practice than to not always the case
the always summer issue some problems
and challenges for example the sale
search this is FDA approvals that answer
460 detection it's not for early
detection cancer detection Ryan and even
only detect CPC involve or t % for
metastatic breast cancer or colorectal
cancer not all patients with metastatic
cancer can be detected when we found
with the CTC so only about forty to
fifty percent of CCC can be detect and
also the another issue is how to
interpret L data overload or
undetectable CTC impatient with the poor
prognosis and I just indicated earlier
the number of CTC is associated with
that deep prognosis right which means
the increased number is associated with
decreased survival or with poor
prognosis for the other hand in this
case how to interpret for those pairs
some of the patients with the low number
or antitakeover CTC but clinically the
prognosis is very poor as a very
progressive so it's a real resumption of
the CTC due to the therapeutic response
or certificate pickasee
no actually not that always usually
indicates the emergence of development
of drug resistance so
that potential mechanism and daddy it's
because tumor cells or cancer cells
they're real smart
they try to adapt the environment how to
develop a new mechanism to against the
therapeutic approach drugs or whatever
again to prevent and to to try to
survive those tumor cells therefore
tumor cells cancer cells themselves to
down-regulate the epithelium mark
markers on the tumors circulating tumor
cell surface like the egg-cam
right when another another issues which
is a very important and very critical is
he called epithelial-mesenchymal
transition so that most of us
circulating tumor cells originally has
experienced sales but they change
developed through mesenchymal cells so
with that change our sherry briefly
again the current asset you know both
sales such an SE and an animal test as
they are not capable of detecting this
CTC once undergoing EMT
epithelial-mesenchymal transition change
once that development so the current has
a wouldn't be able to detect that's why
you know the sale number of CTC number
becomes low or even undetectable but the
prognosis even worse than cancer this
can explain why if this happened why the
city's number hunter take a poll so
epithelial-mesenchymal transition the
EMT normally like I said the solely
tumor cells and 85% are epithelium
orange so those epithelium lying side by
side nicely and show the left top pan
picture and the nice side by side nicely
with the nucleus a little bit polarized
to the base and provides become the EMT
or mesenchymal cells they have an
irregular shape usually become larger
and irregular but not only the physical
change it also undergo
summer genotype and phenotype change for
example if you look the top right panel
to picture shoes that normally the
epithelium cells or tumor cell CTC
there's some expression of e tendrán and
the egg-cam
even the ck8 1819 a docent marker we use
for the detection of CTC right so during
this transition of the East Mt those
markers the expression will be down
regulated or even disappeared but
instead there are new markers will
appear such ends in 10 during and also
remaking fibronectin the problem is with
the disappearance of those regular
markers classic markers so antibodies
against those F kin wouldn't be able to
detect right so that's why became
negative or undetectable but with a new
appearance ok the genotype seen would
have changed also the physical change we
all cause some biological functional
change
so those EMT CTC is circulating tumor
cells become very very aggressive
invasive and most importantly they have
become resistant to chemotherapy and
other therapy and also they are less
prone to episode apoptotic and necrotic
so holding all these cells the
transition with epithelial to
mesenchymal cells makes the CTC become
more resistant and that's one of the
mechanism of drug resistance and also
the part of a mechanism for metastasis
so based on the data we are not our
collaborators and are we work together
develop a specific antibody against cell
surface limiting and I showed in
previous slide with the disappearance
ich enduring and egg-cam but there's
some new expression you know there
always some change something disappear
or something appear something comes out
so
we develop a specific antibody against
the cell surface limiting and use this
anybody with demonstrated this method
this specific animal is able to detect
temperature the new e mt CTC or the CTC
circulating tumor cells undergone
epithelial-mesenchymal transition so it
shows to the lower panel with
demonstrate again these are the lower
left panel shows those against Luke star
because we have to exclude eliminate the
leukocytes in the blood right always hit
because a lot a lot a number a huge
number for leukocytes or what sales
there are nucleated cells you have to
eliminate those but we have key to
eliminate the labor with the antibody
specific an ability here it shows ad 4-1
and this antibody is able to capture the
EMT CTC and should stand to be the
Florence and then using this antibody
will all be able to detect patients and
you can see the bottom right panel shows
with normal healthy group the CTC
undetectable with this specific antibody
which is true which is a reasonable
logical but on the other hand with
Sakuma patient you can see a large
number of CPC detected by this new
method EMT CTC answered all specifically
called antibody 84 work against cell
surface remaking method so then you see
the establishment storages and say we
then analyze those the CTC
in a different patient for example
breast cancer patients and compare the
current methodology with fda-approved
mythology hands okay so this just shows
demonstrate the the new method or EMT
CTC method and antibody against cell
surface momentum works for example
evelope the second
you know you can see the top you can
during speared and it can very much
sustaining the Florence very faint very
much down regulate this indicator each
MIT epithelial-mesenchymal transition of
the CPC but on the other hand you can
see 84 wind antibodies the Florence it's
very intensive and also almost this
again the new antibody with the wealth
to specifically to capture and against
this cell surface limiting for the CTC
undergone EMT and the sustaining the
intensity if you look at and Florence
comparable with the sustain with the
twist snail and the Fox see to Fox see
to those traditional marker used for the
EEM team for mesenchymal staining
antibody so with that development of
this assay the enemy applies it as they
use it as it and run a patient compare
the current FDA approved cell search and
you can see in this slide so we hooked
again we assigned a patient group and
breast cancer patient to two groups with
stable groups other one with the
progression okay so compared to the sale
search method but the CSV method has
better sensitivity and specificity and
you can see a and B between the two
groups and this table just summarized
the parameter specific for sensitivity
specificity positive predict values and
a negative predict value or overall the
CSV method has better performance
compared to the sale search method
then we move to this method use this
mode method to detect colorectal cancer
cells in the patient prefer blood again
we are first we have the Taino straight
this works right the last panel the
picture shows again with the egg-cam
almost disappeared if you look at the
third column the bottom and the head can
be disappeared he can drink very weak
where your faint staining which it means
and very much down regulated but the
8401 staining is still very clear
intensive the Florence compared similar
to other snail swaps to again this used
for the mesenchymal staining that means
and those cells are detected her
mesenchymal cells all the city sees EMT
CTC cells so also we use the in vitro
assay and showing the panel B we Sparkle
the CTC into the Sarah into the blood
and the ratios this method can detect
those with GCC in the tooth depend on
number 7 our number depend responds very
nicely very linear the lie okay then
we'll check our measures account this
patient CTC I specifically EMT CTC using
the specific as a CSV method and you can
see clearly in this is a group several
different group rotation the healthy
group it's very low undetectable CTC but
with the stable group you have a
relatively high number of CTC detected
compared to the healthy group but but a
much much lower than the group with the
progression of progressive disease that
again in a colorectal cancer patient
group high number highly elevated and
acidity increased again this acidity
detectable cell surface limiting
antibody specific against EMT CTC so
clearly that shows the city sees the
taking the EMT CDC sedation can predict
the probe prognosis or the progression
we also test this method in prostate
cancer patients of course first again we
have to demonstrate this method works
for the staining and simulator you can
see this right panel e panel picture and
the bottom the e camp at Camp is pure
and the e candor and disappear you
barely can see the floor and sustaining
again which means this is down regulated
this expression the normal epithelium
molecular cell surface molecular
down-regulate even disappear but with
the further development of he
mesenchymal cells or EMT transition so
as its stained by 8401 antibody against
their surface remaking and similarly to
folks to right and others but also we
use this measure we check over the cell
line first then we will use this muscle
to check the patient samples and you can
see again we compare the two method
fda-approved safe search method
side-by-side for this to group patients
will need to stable other woman's
progressive group so both you can see
with a progressive and also with the
stable group and CSV and also with in
other word eighty-four one handy body
again this has this group has better
performance better sensitivity and show
the B panel and better specificity
and show in the stable group and also we
further analyze compares using ROC curve
again under the ROC ROC curve so the
cells the new methods 84 one method or
CSV method has better performance versus
the tradition of the sale search method
and both
sensitivity specificity are positive
pretty random a negative value also we
use is CPC EMT CDC measure can be
dictated
detect the different states of prostate
cancer and we know PSA knows it's a
tumor of by Omar continues to monitor
disease
Princip regression and the management so
usually as we see the panel C is the
right rub far right to see you see you
know in a patient with hormones
sensitive group and has low which means
response to hormone androgen deprivation
deprivation but with the castration
resistant groups the PSA levels are
elevated but on the panel a you see we
using the new assays CTC method a she
was similar trend prediction again with
the hormone sensitive group CTC numbers
lower compared the castration resistant
which means against a progressive group
right but this B panel be the city
ceases tradition of the current healthy
approach CTC can predict somehow but
still there some outlier which cannot be
predict predictable right but I already
know the CTC method with specifically
CSV method for EMT CDC can be used for
the prediction the progression of
prostate cancer so cancer cells
Oct 30 kg itself has utility but also
has a limitation and we just discussed
but further characterization of
molecular profiling of CT
might shed light or expand extended
utility of the detection of CTC and
therefore we investigate with TD error
expression can be used to predict the
prognosis so PDL 1 heroin is expressed
in these studies slide shows you know
this PDR was singing and she stay
the car in rate and shows there's a
increased expression of his PDL 1 in
these cancer patients and we use
different group and breast colon
prostate osteosarcoma that all these
tumor cells can be stained with the PDL
1 and of course this is CSV positive or
EMT positive CTC which stained by 84 one
antibody and shows in green color
Florence but deadly there's the
increased expression for PDL 1 then we
use this further characterization or
expression of PDL 1 then we analyze CTC
and the talk panel a and B this just
used the CTC or EMT CTC method with you
and we also discussed it earlier can be
used to predict the progression-free
survival also overall survival which is
known and but if you know the lower
panel C and D - C represent
progression-free and D represent overall
survival but with a further
characterization of a ppl worm
expression of CTC
so which means there to save you capture
the CTC then you further tie to the
right with the PD air one expression in
this case we use a nuclear expression of
a PD arrow in in cell nucleus expression
of PDL 1 clearly shows the black line
which is- has a the two lines a blank
line and the kind of c and d the two
lines are clearly separated so the blank
is the dark the blank will represent
negative a PD Erin expression again with
negative or no PDL expressing it has a
longer better survivor prognosis for the
proteases progression-free or the
overall survival so these this means
with the further characterization Molly
characterization of CPC it may extend
the utility of detection CCTV and mostly
most importantly provide additional
information for better and accurate
prognosis we also use this PD our
expression for prostate cancer again
shows the lower panel C and D with the
expression the detection of the
expression with PDL one again it can
predict the prognosis so the PDL
negative staining shows the line the top
line and has longer pedals while
compared to the PD air one positive
staining again positive expression than
always had poor prognosis so please just
indicate again the further
characterization the PDL 1 expression
can be used for the prognosis of
prostate cancer patients and provide
even better additional information at
this again a consistent with the early
study published by dr. Coleman and what
Today Show in this third study you know
with the left panel shows CTC just
regular CTC detection to predict the
survival the overall survival which is
reasonable for the ovary cancer patient
but further that characterizes this is
CTC with the ER cc1 expression again the
group of an ER c serum negative had
shown in the sub grade line and has
longer with no expiry time expression
has a longer better survivor compared to
the ER c7 expression or positive er tc1
and again this CTC staff has a utility
for the further characterization or sub
characterization or molecular profiling
can provide additional information for
the better prognosis
so CCC and also has a correlation with
some a/c cheating and now we talk about
the liquid biopsy always because mostly
which represents circulating tumor cells
and circulating tumor DNA and now Ryan's
ASA so therefore you can see the CT this
is the right panel this is a good
correlation between CTC and circulating
tumor DNA but that means that the same
city TN can be confirmed from neck
rooting apocalyptic tumor cells know to
necessarily come from CTC but on the
other hand CT Co for sure can release
the CT DNA but certainly you can see
sort of a correlation and shows on the
right panel again this is very recent
study shows of the show the detection of
a copy number of aberration in CT t can
predict the survival so the left panel
see a left panel shows with the classic
clinical classification for the
prognosis with the to group between two
groups the right panel shows the
detection determination of a copy number
of aberration in CTC chromosome can
provide better and also the prognostic
information prognosis again with the low
number of copy number of aberration it
has a longer a better survival and shows
the right panel the top is a overall
survival that right low panel has a
progression-free survival but anyway so
with the further characterization and
determination of copy number aberrations
in CTC chromosome can provide a better
prediction
so again just touch a little bit a seat
sitting again it's not a part of a CTC
but certainly to derive or related
circulating tumor cells but of course is
a major panelist and liquid biopsy for
the sister I just showed clearly with a
copy number or the mound with
circulating tumor the
a detail in the blood can predict the
survival predict survival and you can
see that somebody talked to the blue
line shows a high copy number as the
worst prognosis a shortage of survival
why with the low number 25% of quote on
CT being enhanced better the longer
survival which means the number of the
model Kotov number of ctva are
associated with the decrease the
prognosis for survival so the detection
of a CTC can be used as succeeding as or
can be used for the prognosis but that's
a of the topic the CPC talk but it's
somehow related to share with you
briefly so Collier and we discussed so
far we know CTC has it the utility can
be used for prognosis and also to
monitor therapy therapy especially when
you move further characterize the CTC
with EMT antibody and also with some
characterization new molecular markers
PDL 1 year GRCC 1 and also other the
copy number right 460 crumby again this
project characterization will provide
additional information and extend its
utility but however this not always the
case or the idiot has also has a
limitation so this currently for example
CTC measurements have not been included
into the clinical guidelines because
it's clinical utility still not quite
clear and technically it has a low
sensitivity for detection it's about 1
CTC is detecting 7.5 millimeters of Hope
right so the standard is to collect 7.5
milliliter and then you can't measure
how many CT to detect in 7.5 millimeters
the sensitivity is very low right when
tumor cells in 7.5 millimeters broad and
it's only in order all patient with the
metastasis can be detected with CTC
it's only detectable about in 30 to see
2% cancer patient even with the late
stage with many societies and also
during you know there is the current
sales urgent and long process of
isolation and separation so during this
can cause some change apoptosis
deformation of elongation this may
affect the specificity against multiple
state oscillation can damage cells
impact with recovery and accuracy and
also when you are data file still human
determined it's an operated judgment
right it can be subjective counts when
you count the Florence pain CTC there's
a big variation coefficient of variation
is about fifty over even some percent
variation it's a little bit subjective
and also there's some techniques there
are length even though there are a
number of techniques being established
relevant but still there are length of
new techniques for City T enrichment and
isolation mostly due to the sensitivity
and specificity of course those I and
this equation which city is only
approved so far for FDA approval only
for breast cancer colorectal cancer and
also prostate cancer right so still only
of limited and not to expand it to the
other type cancer and also keeping my
tumor cells are very fit Regina's right
therefore there's no Universal markers
that's another limitation challenge and
also we know we learned that tumor cells
try to attempt new environment and to
smile so there's four there's always a
bound regulation of those markers but
the current technology would will miss
that detection won't be able to detain
right mostly significant is called
epithelial-mesenchymal transition right
when the cells undergone that state EMT
the current technology wouldn't be able
to detect so therefore wouldn't be able
to provide accurate of predictive
information and also this detection
rigidity only used for prognosis right
not for early detection
and there are some pre-analytical issue
sample collection and also sansa
standardization automation especially
control external controls there's no we
do just P of course we use peer group
evaluation assessment for external
quality control but this cap does not
provide who has no proficiency testing
survey material and also there are lots
of new devices techniques technology but
those but for those a CPC but again the
northern way of validated for clinical
use especially not aware defined for
clinical endpoint whether this
technology this detection for CTC using
this technology can improve our overall
survival a little bit at this point
point point is and the face risks works
it's 100 trial fair to demonstrate and
CTC are good marker in guidance therapy
in women with metastatic breast cancer
so but anyway we just discussed the
limitation right but you know there's a
lot of limitation and challenge however
CTC is not there yet the detection of
acidity is not that dead it's not in
life but still some lost opportunity and
also the opportunity and to develop for
the further development new technology
so currently the new technology have
been developing and validating we know
the example is a large super large blood
volume filtration and by so-called a
sale collector and also the technology
technique for leukapheresis right which
can be used because whenever the issue
we measure in say low sensitivity only
detect one cell tumor cell in seven
point five millimeter so with this
technology you'll be able to filter to
search larger volume blood you don't
have to collect heart of the body
individual right you can just circulate
with
you have a chance opportunity increase
the sensitivity opportunity to capture
tumour cells but other technology could
be some point air tracks - dainius
detections I'm using some sensor
technology to detect capture or detect
at least tumor cells there are the new
technologies such as telomerase activity
have such technology so fish flow
cytometry molecular techniques rt-pcr
deep sequencing and next-generation
sequencing these are being used for the
detection of an awesome molecular
profiling of tumor cells and of course
this new methodology are being validated
for various type of cancer beyond those
three types of cancer which are approved
by FDA and of course other interesting
areas thus it is excreted or related
release protein markers into the
circulation so in theory and CTC will be
has a very active in my families so they
can release something in particles
protein into the circulation capture of
this protein will be very useful
valuable for the determination for
cancer right and also this can be used
to expand this new technology out for
CDC's determination can be used to house
the top cancer such as a long liver
pancreas or area right and also future
study should be also focused on
molecular profiling characterization of
CTC this already been done a report such
as IGF
EGFR her to a banker Karen Terrace GRCC
one right and again most importantly the
reason you later
this is genotyping for mutation of CTC
uses called singles cancer tumor cell
genetic mutation sequencing right this
can be used to guide therapy targeted
therapy which is part of a companion
diagnostics so as the two material
particles such as the circulating tumor
a micro Emily circulating tumor micro
basic
and exercise this contains lots of
information being an army again this can
be used I have been used now still under
validation process so most importantly
is the tumour derived nucleic acid right
that we know is kept on a micron
especially the circulating freezing all
specifically circulating tumor dinging
that being measure now that used in the
clear lab or in the many critical
laboratory laboratories and especially
then for the sequencing using the TP PCR
or next NGS sequencing and this and part
for liquid biases heart biopsy guiding
well targeted therapy are being used so
again this slide pictures shows there's
a potential expansion to the traditional
sweet have cancer to other types such as
an alarm
plan plan cancer pancreatic cancer
hepatocellular carcinoma and also ovary
cancer and with the further a
characterization also molecular
profiling of these tumor cells again in
the work shed light light and also bring
additional information for prognosis and
most importantly guiding therapy so in
term even the interment of a tumor cell
isolation and even for the research
purpose you know think about research in
vitro study you do whether the drug
sensitivity suspect ability sensitivity
study so the isolation of a tumor cells
from the human body from a cancer
patient would be much much more relevant
compared to stare lying right so this is
over are provided very useful tool to
study drugs - drugs and drug resistance
right and also to study the biological
mechanism again it's much more relevant
compared to cell line because you seem
from it really from tumor cancer
patients to study biology tumor biology
tumorigenesis the mechanism of
metastasis and also and again
specifically for even for the targeted
therapy so the most involved
for tumor cells CTC isolation now that
the being use and study it's called
single to cancer cell mutation a
sequencing single cancer cell sequencing
for those isolation of a single cell and
then further molecular profiling
mutation detection and sequencing and
this can be used for guiding therapy
targeted therapy so just to summarize
again the future is during the liquid so
CTC detection CDC a potential valuable
resource for personalized cancer therapy
and it can be used for prognosis it can
be used to predict the prognosis it can
be used especially with the single
cancers there are sequence sequencing
with the mutation analysis and mutation
detection can be used to guide the
targeted therapy it can be used
monitored disease progression and also
to tracked the resistance during the
cause for therapy during the course of
disease
he's a minimum invasive and part of a
liquid biopsy and also but that not
again that's not enough with the CTC
itself as we discussed has limitations
but certainly the next step will be
moved to further to cellular and
molecular level and molecular analysis
specifically for CTC and also CTC
related
circulating tumor DNA RNA micron long
non-coding RNA and multiple mutation
analysis which is a part of genotyping
and precision medicine and most usefully
use mostly used for guiding the therapy
of course for prognosis and potentially
can be used for early detection again
with then I like to thank my colleagues
for their support and the collaboration
and also I like to thank the audience
for their attention and also like the
saxons lab
for giving the opportunity to share with
you my experience and thank you very
much dr. Ming for that informative
presentation it's time for Q&A if I have
a question you'd like to ask please do
so now just click on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click on the send button will answer
as many questions as we have time for if
we are unable to get to your question we
will follow up with you via email after
the presentation let's get started our
first question is the youth for early
diagnosis of cancer No and other things
are not on this momentum with the
current technology although there are
many technologies being valued and I
used for detection of CTE
currently there are only two measures
being approved for clinical use so when
in the sale search and I was going to
add in the tests and all these are used
for prognosis and monitoring the
therapeutic response or patient with the
metastatic cancer so in principle a1
CDC's to detect in the blood it always
means at least middle to late stage in
other words this means to be patient
with the metastasis so it's not an early
stage and not for early detection
diagnosis however with the improvement
of sensitivity of CTC detection
technology and maybe other techniques
such as molecular profiling and genetic
mutation analysis this might become
possible it was new the next question is
what are the major challenges of
detection of CTCs yes as I discussed in
my presentation although that detection
CDs is clinically useful so we are still
facing many challenges and city seed
detention facility itself still has very
much limitation for example CDC
measurements have not been included into
the clinical guideline has still needs
more clinical evidence this may hamper
its clinical application in the
technical part the tip education
technology has low sensitivity so it
only detect one tumor cells in 7.5
millimeters the sensitivity and also
only detectable in the smaller portion
30 60 % of metastatic cancer patients so
also there's some specificity issues
during the process isolation of CTC the
cells may be damaged became apoptotic
for change of the faulty form elongated
so this will affect the specificity of
CTC and also the recovery act accuracy
and the even though there are new
techniques technology for CDT enrichment
isolation but again this need to be
aware of validated again currently
they're not FDA approved so also cancer
cell had undergone some epithelial to
mesenchymal transition change right and
this makes it difficult for the current
technology to detect these cells in
cancer patients especially in the cancer
patient late stage cancer patient so
there are also some a pre hydrocal issue
standard duration quality control and
especially external quality control
there's no handle all have the efficient
testing material for this evaluation the
performance yeah we have time for one
more question and that question is what
can you foresee the future perspective
of CTC research okay thank you
yes CTC and part of a liquid biopsy is
advancing rapidly there there are and
there will be a new technologies for
shield facility detection certain
current emerging like a fish flow
cytometry and molecular techniques and
rt-pcr deep sequencing
next-generation sequencing and of course
validation of this new assay for
clinical utility provide further
opportunity for clinical application
to detect more than other the three type
of cancer breast colorectal or prostate
right can be moved to full on liver
pancreas ovary cancer so also CTC and we
know can secrete or release lots of
particles which contain lots and lots of
information such as excess on Mac micro
vesicle mother Condry so these should be
analyzed could be analyzed and may
provide a better predicting information
for cancer even is making it biological
mechanisms of guiding the therapy also
some future study could be possible to
focus a molecular profiling a
characterization of CTC itself you know
you cause so-called single CTC
sequencing or mutation mutation again
genetic genomic analysis this could be
used and the part of a target therapy or
guiding the target therapy and part of a
precision medicine precision tumor
medicine and other parts the tumor
derived nucleic acid now we talked about
honey a micron a CT being a again this
special CCD is emerging as a part of a
liquid biopsy with the next molecular
sequencing by the TTP GRP PCR and also
next generation sequencing heart being
used to Guardians therapy has a liquid
biopsy and other kind of a genotype of
mutation and I see CDC also can be
potentially
validated and used for companion
diagnostics and further for precision
magazine I would like to once again
thank dr. min for his presentation do
you have any final comments so I think
it's fun ecologist those anyway just to
be aware the current the CTC is a
utility of the current technology it has
a utility but also has a limitation but
on the other hand certainly it also
gives a lot of potential for further
development in the future thanks most
again dr. Mary I would also like to
thank lab routes were making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
armed
through January 12 2008 teams you will
receive an email elaborates letting you
know when this webcast will be available
for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
that's awesome well thank you for
joining us we hope to see you again soon
goodbye
[Music]